hey guys how's it going it's to Steven
today we are checking out Apple new app
clips it's here I talked about it a
little bit in my iOS 10.3 update video
so I'm super excited to show it to you
guys if you haven't updated iOS 10.3 do
so check out the app and let me know
what you guys think
share your movies with me I would love
to see what you guys make it how far you
can push this app something that I love
about it at its core focus is it's super
super simple like it's so easy to make a
video that I don't think there's anybody
out there that's not going to be able to
use this well I also like is I felt like
I was kind of pushing the boundaries of
yes it's extremely simple but you can do
so much more with it and more that you
actually play with it so that's a little
bit of here that I made well I went on a
hike let's go for a hike there's Jenna
ready to hike let's just jump right into
this I'm gonna give you guys a quick
little tutorial and then I'm going to
fix up that video that I shot previously
I'm gonna make a video for my sister
Jenna hi Jenna
how are you I don't have anything to say
so here's the clip that I shot hi Jenna
so you can go in you can trim it so I'm
actually just going to trim this - hi
Jenna
how are you so we're going to go back
into that text oh that's crazy you know
what I don't actually like that I think
I want it to look like this how are you
here are some different filters let's
see since that's kind of a comic book
style I'm going to choose the comic book
one you can also add soldiers to your
pre reports videos hi Jenna
so in this clip I'm going to add a
healthy here I'm going to just add this
hi there let's see what it look like
Nana how are you this video is getting
pretty wild okay now we're going to do
another holder report that I want to
remove all of this craziness that I just
made so these kind of just use four
different filters you already have built
into your camera so let's talk to any of
the live-text
[Music]
so somebody really say anything in this
clip you can actually decide if you want
the audio on or off when you're
recording it but for me I might want to
go back and actually use the audio of
something so I would always recommend
recording it on just in case you decide
hey I want that but if you don't right
here is the little microphone you can
just click that on click it off and you
can see here I'm talking so the little
waveforms are kind of moving around up
on just leave it on it can't hurt so
next I'm going to share some pictures of
Maddie with Jenna this is him from
earlier this is probably one of my
favorite features so any photos that you
take
you've been hold the button to record
and you can zoom in on the picture and
move it around and it will record pretty
much the movement that you make on the
screen on the photo I'm going to leave
the audio on I'm gonna hold your record
and I'm gonna you'll see what happens
look at Maddie he's hiding under my desk
look at him he's a beautiful little boy
maybe 90 90 Maddie Maddie mess there it
is look at it oh my goodness this is so
cool it's just so easy that I can't even
believe it I'm gonna add music you can
use anything that you already have
purchased on iTunes through your music
we're going to go in and use some of the
music they already have selected so I'm
gonna just pick I don't know I'm just
going to pick one randomly so we're
gonna pick this one
suffering and one of the things that I
think is so important about editing is
music I love having a good soundtrack to
my vlogs to videos to anything that I do
and what's great about this is it
auto-adjust right to your timeline so
here we go hi Jenna
how are you looking Mady he's hiding
under my desk look into the beautiful
little boy anyways now before I had the
audio muted on the second clip so the
audio automatically just faded up just
beautifully and that's my wonderful
videos or Jenna go back to video you can
also add other videos too so inside of
your library
let's see you just up with this little
video of Madyan so you just hold to add
the clip and I'll basically hold however
long this clip is so if you want to stop
you just lift up we're done you can go
in I'm going to add like let's see how
at this little ink and you know what I
don't think I want the audio on this one
to play so I'm going to stop it you can
mute reported audio mute original audio
I'm going to meet my recorded audio I'm
going to meet the original oh that's
cool it gives you two options let's
download some text the end
[Music]
turn off the audio hi well I think it's
a nasty work of art so another thing is
actually pretty cool as I said Jenna's
name is beginning so it'll kind of
search through your contacts to see if
there's any other Jenna's if it's a
Jenna that you talk to pretty often
it'll automatically populate that and
there is there's Jenna I've lured all
the other people that I'm talking to you
for the sake of their privacy so now I'm
just going to click to send it to Jenna
automatically shares the video right to
her I message MERIS so that's clips in a
nutshell now I'm going to go back and
finish up the little vlog that I made
previously and see what you guys think
I'm going to be interested to see if
they ever open it up to sort of be sort
of the 16 by 9 aspect ratio but I will
say there hasn't been anything that I've
seen that has been this good to be able
to make beautiful square videos wait
what are you doing back there buddy how
much fun making video so my one may note
on the live subtitling is yeah it
definitely works does it work 100% every
single time no of course not have you
guys ever use Siri she definitely gets
things confused every once in a while so
this is kind of the same thing but
what's cool about it it gives a lot so
as you're talking and if it says
something wrong you can just do it again
so all of these clips that I have in
here I filmed inside of the clips app
and it was actually super easy in kind
of a whole different way of making
videos because I was basically making my
video clip by clip but I was able to see
what I was doing creating the story in
the timeline moving clips around I
definitely it wasn't enjoying the hike
as much as I was creating the video as
you'll see Jenna was getting annoyed
with me because she's like can you
please hike and get off your phone so to
go through here and I think one of my
favorite examples of subtitles not
working 100% was this one let me show it
to you we just went up two small hills
and I think my body is shutting down
lack of business all doubt I think it's
pretty funny how I thought that I said
lack of food what no no no I was talking
about lack of fitness if you guys have
ever used Siri or any type of voice of
text you're going to run into these
issues but for the most part if you're
talking to it pretty clearly it
understand view is yes it but I think
the one thing that it doesn't get is
contact I mean the day the machines
start understanding context completely a
hundred percent oh boy
so for that clip I just
live subtitling so if you do fill it
with the live subtitles you'll have this
little option up here to either turn it
on or turn it off
so one of the things to to note is
you're not able to turn it on after you
have to turn it on before so if this is
something that you think that you might
want to use later make sure you turn it
on so here's where I've got my drone
clip clip clip so it's also kind of cool
cuz you can move these Clips around if
you've ever used iMovie on your iPhone
it's pretty much that same thing so
we're going to delete this one set it
like it actually this one so right here
I said if you have some really great
throne shots but guess what I don't have
any drone shots in here yet let's go
into our library and I already have this
drone shot that I put on to my computer
and wonder if this will work if I hold a
record can I move in the video let's see
let's try it I'm going to turn my audio
off because I don't really want to hear
myself talking holding holding holding
oh you totally can that's awesome let's
see if it worked
oh that's so cool
and no I hear you can do that
[Music]
how to just want to have a short little
clip oh my god it's so cool so I love
flying drone so much it's my favorite
thing in the world to be honest with you
then drop that in and we're going to put
that in right right in between here that
was a little bit too long so I'm going
to cut that down a little bit you know
what's cool about this is I actually
have my audio turned off but it still
picked up what I was saying so even
though my audio was inaudible it still
picked up the subtitles oh you can even
scrub right here this is so awesome
great drone shot awesome dog clipped
let's just do a little while over okay
I'm going to do something I'm wearing so
much fun TV I'll do like a nice little
chrome filter here on the ones where I
don't have audio so it's kind of like
cool montage is this a feature of
editing I think so
okay well that's my video I think I'm
done let me add like a little anything
I'll just add an on-the-road because why
not so we're on the road right oh I
brought to show you guys this - so when
you're recording your video you can
slide and it'll just let you record just
like this yeah that was my little video
so let's just let's take a little debut
of it shall we let's go for a hike
there's Jenna ready to hike we've been
trying to go on this hike for about
three hours and I take forever to do
anything
[Music]
we just went up two small hills and I
think my body is shutting down
lack of physics Oh No how's it going
down slow
[Music]
we just got some super cool drone shots
you look cool look like a tourist I
think I see a lizard right here well the
lizard all is actually a shadow of this
amazing hairdo this isn't even that long
of a hike and I'm winded Jen why are you
doing
unfortunately I finished my Starbucks
like it's time for round two
[Music]
you
okay that was actually a lizard
[Music]
take over oh let's go home you got hit
by so many pong oh great hike though bye
we have us clips let me know what you
guys think and I will see you in my next
video bye oh god oh god eggs
this is not what I expected to happen
because I'll just shave off the side of
our omelets